[Music]
and so this was goodbye
[Music]
until now scotland has been the focus of
our nation's farewell
now it shifts south
the departure of the queen's coffin from
edinburgh sinjal's cathedral was the
final act of a goodbye here
to public applause
they queued through the hours of
darkness here to pay their respects
walking past the queen's coffin as she
lay at rest a vigil mounted by her
traditional bodyguard the royal company
of archers
the queue continued into daylight hours
tens of thousands shuffled through
edinburgh streets in a collective show
of remembrance we're kind of all
tingling at the moment because there's a
poignancy now
to waiting and paying our respects and
it's uh it's been incredible for the
city of edinburgh it's been incredible
for the people of scotland the queen was
like a very great queen yeah yeah
because she was on the front for 70
years
she conducted lots of music and we want
to like pay our respects when my dad
came to this country
she was the reigning queen and he passed
away just a few years ago so for me
showing my respects it's part of my
culture it's part of my religion at the
very back of a very long line was 89
year old janet sharp who traveled from
glasgow
in 1953
she bought her first television set to
watch the queen's coronation
beautiful beautiful so sombre and
it was lovely to see
that was lovely
where the queen's coffin has been
transported in scotland crowds have
lined the route
so it was as she was driven to the
airport accompanied by her daughter the
princess royal
they left behind images of a scottish
farewell that lasted over two days
with a thanksgiving service as its
centerpiece
remembrance here was ceremonial and yet
centered around the people
[Music]
is
[Music]
scotland has seen the start of a process
of public engagement in the queen's
passing
[Music]
it will only increase in scale as a
nation north and south works through the
loss of a monarch dearly departed
james matthews sky news edinburgh